so for a decade michelle tafoya was a
highly recognizable reporter for nbc
sports she covered hundreds of nfl games
as a sideline reporter including five
super bowls she worked at multiple
olympics
dealt with you've seen some of her
interviews over the years here's a
sampler including her coverage of the
super bowl this past sunday
erin
obviously
emotional
what's the immediate feeling you've got
right now i'm just so happy
i wanna get so bad i dreamed this man
i dreamed this and it's like
it's surreal look at this shelter foyer
retiring from sportscasting michelle we
love you you have been so much fun
and we'll hear a lot more from her you
and i don't know what the future holds
pal
so that was sunday this is wednesday
after nearly 30 years covering sports
michelle tafoya's decided to step away
from nbc sport she said she made the
decision wholly on her own she was not
forced out
and she's doing it because she wants to
be in a role where she can speak openly
there's nothing we're in favor of more
than that we're honored to have michelle
tafoya join us tonight to explain
michelle first of all congratulations on
this new chapter what an interesting
decision that you made why did you make
it
it's been on my mind for quite a while
tucker thank you for having me and no
nbc did not encourage this they did not
force this this has been on my mind i've
been waking up
every day with a palpable pull at my
gut
that
my side my view my my middle ground kind
of moderate
viewpoint is not being represented yeah
to the rest of the world i didn't feel
and um and so
rather than you know just banging it out
on twitter or instagram every day i
thought
i've got to do something i have
benefited greatly from the american
dream and i feel like for the sake of my
kids and because i so love this country
i've got to start giving back
boy that is the best possible reason
so
people who watch sports of course know
you and have for many years you went on
the view recently which is a slightly
different venue
for you we have just a short clip and i
want to ask if this had some role in
your decision here it is
my kids in school there is a big big
focus on the color of your skin
children my children are now
16 and 13.
it's been going on since they were in
lower school all right and it is that
there are affinity groups on campus for
my my son's first best friend was a
little african-american boy they were in
inseparable
get to a certain age they start having
what's called an affinity group which
means you go for lunch and pizza with
people who look like you
suddenly my son wasn't hanging out with
him anymore why are we even teaching
that the color of the skin
matters because to me what matters is
your character and your voice but you
know you live in the united states you
know that color of skin has been
mattering to people can't we change it
we need white people to step up and do
that but i think that we they've been
doing that since the civil war and i'm
not saying no no no no
wow that was such a such a moderate
thing to say such a sensible thing to
say
um and yet it seemed like such a
controversial thing i thought that was
really brave that you said that what did
you think of the reaction
i'm just astonished that we're
we're so looking in the rearview mirror
and not absorbing the progress that
we've made in this country and building
on it and recognizing it
um
you know
i don't think a person like whoopi
goldwork goldberg would have had that
role 50 years ago she has that now i
mean that
i i you and i know tucker we could come
up with a million examples and it breaks
my heart
that my kids are being taught that skin
color
matters and to me
if you want white people to step up i
was stepping up when i addressed the
school and said
why are we having these picnics for
families of color why are we separating
our kids
the world is integrated let's continue
that and and and have everyone find out
what we all have in common not just what
we have in common with people who look
like us
man uh you know i i would i bet you 20
bucks that 95 of americans agree with
what you just said and
i but to say that when you work at nbc
sports or any big media company really
takes i mean you must have known that
you would be attacked
for defending the american ideal as you
did why did you do that
because i don't care if i'm attacked
i really am not afraid of that and i
guess i feel like so many people now are
afraid
yeah and
i'm not
um listen i know there are repercussions
for whatever i choose to say
uh i and i've talked to my kids school
about it you know please don't hold this
against my kids i'm speaking for me i'm
speaking for my family but please don't
hold this against my kids but this is
what i really believe i think i speak
for a lot of people like you said tucker
and a lot of these people my friends
are afraid to
repost things that i've posted
or you know get into political
conversations they are and they've said
it i'm afraid i don't want to get in
these arguments with my friends with my
boss with my colleagues
this is the most terrifying thing in the
world to me right now that people are
afraid to talk
these are words coming out of our mouths
yeah we could probably hurt people with
our words i acknowledge that but i get
to choose my reaction to everybody's
words and everybody else gets to choose
their reaction to my words so they can
choose to react to what i say
i'm going to choose to to say what i
believe and what i feel very strongly
about and and
um i'm going to continue this and and
this is this is the direction i'm headed
i just love it so much and i and i think
personal bravery like the kind that you
have displayed in our display now
is deeply inspiring to people and
comforting and really is the answer to
where we are so thank you for what
you're doing i hope people will join me
i hope people will join me tucker
well if you keep doing it people will so
that's why it's so great to see it thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else